I accept whatever words they give me - to stop a little bit of a poet's war play
One day I will swallow I
Hope you all perished violently
That the motherfucking
Now you look like shit I look like I always look
you have pissed away your talent on women and booze and
Now you're talking that's obscene two juices up here in my noggin man, I get all these things going
They start to music the world's reverberating back and forth and hit the frequencies
I start to dance to it my fingers get moving
Spinning all over the fucking place
And the fucking words come out
No stops now the foolishness you're gonna publish your novel and if you mess this up is Chilton
Wish me luck. I'm off to write the next great American novel. I may have a gangbang when I get back
I will invite your mother. Thank you. Miss Moore dog
I'm trying to uncover my connection miss the world. Just follow me, my friend
Let's go where see good pilot mom and you got glaucoma Buffy sighs it's perfect
I'm gonna shoot something shoot this in here now. I gotta feed my coach addicted hurt. Yes set him up
You